die uroma zecken sind nicht nur dreimal
größer als die hiesigen zecken
sie jagen ihrer beute sogar aktiv hinter
her und können zudem auch noch
gefährliche krankheiten übertragen und
fachleute schlagen jetzt alarm immer
mehr dieser zecken werden in deutschland
aufgespürt und nicht nur das die
fachleute sind davon überzeugt dass die
tropischen zecken anders als im letzten
jahr erfolgreich in deutschland
überwintert haben kriegs um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nicht
herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich gruselig die hammer
zecken lauern ihren opfern in erdhöhlen
auf und gehen dann selbst auf die jagd
sie verfolgen ihre beute zum teil über
mehrere hundert meter und laufen dabei
so schnell wie spinnen auf pferde rinder
schafe oder ziegen zu aber auch menschen
kommen als potenzieller wird für diese
tropischen zecken in frage
und jetzt steht fest sie sind wieder da
schon letztes jahr wurde eine größere
anzahl an tieren in deutschland
nachgewiesen
im juni folgen jetzt weitere sechs hunde
fünf dieser zecken wurden an einem
pferdehof in nordrhein-westfalen
aufgespürt eine weitere auf einem pferd
in niedersachsen die pfunde passierten
praktisch zeitgleich so dass experten
und expertinnen davon ausgehen dass die
tiere durch die vergangenen heißen tage
an verschiedenen orten aktiv wurden dazu
ute mackenstedt von der universität
hohenheim
wir haben die ersten nachweise dieses
jahres von roma zecken in deutschland
und diesmal müssen wir davon ausgehen
dass diese tiere bei uns in deutschland
überwintern von eigentlich kommen die
zecken der gartensommer in den trocken
und halbtrocken gebieten von asien
afrika und süd europa vor die beiden
arten namens la loma magie nato
mundhöhle ruf ibis übertragen wirklich
super gefährlichen krankheiten
beispielsweise das virus des krim kongo
hämorrhagischen fiebers und des
arabischen hämorrhagischen fiebers die
tiere können zudem auch das bakterium
ricketts slimani übertragen wodurch eine
form des zecken fleck fiebers ausgelöst
wird als wird nutzen die erwachsenen
tiere große tiere aber auch der mensch
kann ihnen zum opfer fallen die larven
und die nymphen dagegen halten sich eher
auf
garantieren auf so können sie mit
zugvögeln auch nach deutschland gelangen
doch laut der fachleute ist dies bei den
aktuellen kunden quasi ausgeschlossen
dazu ute mackenstedt wenn man den
entwicklungszyklus zurück rechnet hätten
sie zu einem zeitpunkt eingeschleppt
werden müssen als die zügel noch gar
nicht da war doch dass die tiere damit
also tatsächlich auch heimisch in
deutschland sind bedeutet ihr
überwintern nicht unbedingt denn dafür
müssen sich zunächst weibchen und
männchen finden und eine population
bilden auch in einem weiteren punkt kann
man bislang entwarnung geben denn keines
der bislang aufgespürt die ihren trug
infektionserreger wie zum beispiel das
krim kongo virus in sich
laut robert-koch-institut konnten höher
lama zecken in deutschland seit 2017
nachgewiesen werden 2010 waren es
insgesamt 18 exemplare und zwar in acht
verschiedenen bundesländern unter
anderem in hessen berlin bayern und
schleswig holstein die zecken
unterscheiden sich deutlich von den
hiesigen zecken wenn sie sind eben nicht
nur deutlich größer sondern haben auch
geringelte beine
man könnte sie im ersten moment
vielleicht sogar für eine spinne halten
durch ihre größe machen sie sich auch
auf ihrem opfer bemerkbar den angriff
der hammer zecken können wir also spüren
dazu mackenstedt sie ist ja deutlich
größer das merken sie wenn die auf ihnen
herum läuft vielleicht ein kleiner trost
im gegensatz zu den hier heimischen
gemeinen holzbock ja auch eine zecke
übertragen die tropischen zecken weder
borreliose noch
frühsommer-meningoenzephalitis fsme zwei
ziemlich schlimme infektionen jetzt
liegt es an den experten und expertinnen
mehr über die tiere herauszufinden und
im auge zu behalten ob sie tatsächlich
in deutschland heimisch werden bayerns
gefährlichste wiese mit zecken forschern
in der oberpfalz anklicken hier und
anschauen unbedingt sehr spannend bis
dann bleibt dran